Trascrizione: Ilaria Feltrin
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Vi ricordate come erano i vostri sogni,
quando eravate piccoli?
Quei sogni rivelano ciò che siamo,
e ciò che vogliamo diventare.
Eccomi.
Questa sono io, a quattro anni:
è una foto del mio primo saggio di danza.
Ricordo perfettamente la mia felicità
nel indossare le mie
prime scarpette, il mio primo body
e di condividere il mio tempo
con altre bambine.
Ho frequentato la mia prima lezione
in una scuola locale della mia città,
Khorovodarte,
e da lì non ho mai smesso di ballare.
Ognuno di voi, ne sono certa,
ha qualcosa cui proprio
non riesce a smettere di pensare
e magari ci pensa ancora.
Per me è la danza.
All'età di 11 anni
ho iniziato a fare i primi concorsi,
e inoltre cercavo stage
in giro per l'Italia.
Solo la danza riusciva
a farmi provare certe emozioni,
dalla rabbia alla sofferenza,
dalla felicità alla leggerezza.
Queste emozioni prendevano
forma nello spazio.
Non avevo però altri passatempi,
molti sport o altro tempo libero.
Realizzare i propri sogni, però,
non è facile come salire
i gradini di una scala;
e molto spesso, la maggior parte di noi
si incaglia alle prime cadute.
A me, il peggiore di questi momenti
è capitato nel maggio del 2012:
il terremoto dell'Emilia.
Quel giorno io persi mia mamma,
che rimase sotto le macerie del capannone
dove lavorava insieme a mio papà.
E di quel giorno io ricordo
la paura, e il dolore,
di perdere la persona a me più cara.
Ma è di fronte a tragedie così immense
che si può decidere di reagire
o di fuggire da tutto,
anche dai propri sogni.
Io ho deciso di reagire,
e ho trovato la forza nella danza.
Non abbiate paura
nel fare determinate scelte,
perché queste possano farvi prendere
il giusto cammino nella vita.
La danza, quindi, era diventata
il mio punto fermo, la mia passione.
Volevo arrivare, e volevo diventare
una ballerina professionista;
ma avevo 16 anni e abitavo
in una piccola città di provincia,
e mi mancava il mio punto di riferimento.
Avevo però tanto coraggio
e determinazione: volevo arrivare.
Feci dei video per delle audizioni
in accademie straniere;
ma ogni volta ricevetti solo dei no,
e ogni volta era un’amarezza.
Però credo che prima o poi un'occasione
si presenti davanti alla porta di tutti;
e magari non è facile
da vedere, ma arriva.
Quel giorno, l'accademia
a cui puntavo di più,
l'English National
Ballet School di Londra,
mi diede l'opportunità di frequentare.
Io ero felicissima: ma allo stesso tempo,
come potevo lasciare la mia famiglia?
Come potevo mantenermi
in una città così costosa?
Ma soprattutto, come potevo
lasciare perdere quest'occasione?
Le occasioni, infatti,
da sole possono non bastare.
A volte arrivano
quando meno ce lo aspettiamo,
o comunque arrivano quando
non possiamo più permettercele.
Io, però, sono stata fortunata.
Ho condiviso la mia storia,
e mi sono accorta che non ero sola:
avevo tanta gente intorno a me
pronta a sostenermi;
e in quegli anni
post-terremoto, ancora così bui,
le mie insegnanti di danza,
e la mia comunità,
hanno iniziato a creare
questa grande campagna di crowdfunding.
Poi, improvvisamente,
sono stati organizzati
eventi di beneficenza
e si è creato questo grande
tam tam on line
dove sono state raccolte
tante piccole somme,
anche da persone
a me del tutto sconosciute,
alle quali sarò eternamente grata.
Ed è così che si sono aperte le porte
dell'English National
Ballet School di Londra.
Il mio sogno cominciava ad avverarsi.
Avevo 16 anni, e non ero
mai stata all'estero prima.
Conoscevo un po’ l'inglese,
ma temevo di non riuscire
a comunicare come avrei voluto.
Tuttavia, armata di coraggio,
ero pronta per partire
per questa nuova avventura.
L'inizio di nuove esperienze,
però, può fare paura.
Ma se, durante il percorso,
riusciamo a incontrare persone
che fanno la differenza,
le si affrontano con meno difficoltà.
L'inizio è stato difficile, non lo nego;
ma durante il percorso ho incontrato
persone a me ancora oggi molto speciali.
Il loro aiuto è stato fondamentale,
perché se non mi fossi sentita a mio agio
probabilmente avrei mollato.
L'inizio di un percorso
di crescita professionale, e personale,
richiede molto impegno,
ma direi efficace per non arrendersi
alla prima difficoltà.
I primi giorni di scuola
sono stati molto pesanti:
ma alla fine di ogni giornata,
avevo la conferma
che quello che stavo facendo
mi faceva stare bene.
Nonostante però la stanchezza
si facesse sentire.
L'Accademia, infatti, pretendeva:
rigore; autodisciplina;
puntualità; autocontrollo;
rispetto dei ruoli.
Dovevo assolutamente stringere i denti,
perché ogni mia debolezza
avrebbe interrotto il mio percorso.
E le occasioni, come dicevo,
a volte possono non bastare.
E la danza, quindi,
era diventata come dicevo
il mio punto di riferimento.
E quell'anno, il secondo anno di scuola,
ricevetti una bellissima notizia.
Ero stata selezionata nel tour del "Lago
dei Cigni" in giro per l'Inghilterra.
Ero stata selezionata
come Odile, il cigno nero.
Ero felicissima,
ma allo stesso tempo ero molto preoccupata
perché era una parte
tecnicamente molto difficile
e avevo questo grande senso
di responsabilità verso la compagnia,
che mi aveva dato così tanta fiducia.
Però andò bene:
e l'anno dopo un'altra soddisfazione,
al London Coliseum, ne "Lo Schiaccianoci";
e nel 2019 alla Royal Albert Hall
come "Cinderella", di Wheeldon.
Era un sogno che stava diventando realtà.
Secondo la mia opinione,
la danza è una professione che ti insegna
sia artisticamente che umanamente.
Fin da piccoli, la danza insegna
ad avere tanta autodisciplina
sia nel modo di presentarsi
che nel modo di collaborare con gli altri.
Io immagino la mia vita
un po’ come una danza,
perché tante sono le cose in comune.
La danza richiede la memorizzazione
di lunghi passaggi e tanta concentrazione.
Quando si balla da soli
tutto è molto più semplice,
perché la gestione dello spazio,
e il corretto movimento,
dipendono tutte da me.
Ma noi, nella nostra vita,
non balliamo mai da soli,
è quasi sempre una coreografia di gruppo;
e in una coreografia di gruppo,
i ballerini devono avere mille occhi,
coordinarsi e creare armonia.
Gli imprevisti, nella vita,
possono capitare:
ma noi dobbiamo cercare
di fare di essi qualcosa di abituale,
Quasi come se li avessimo programmati.
Capita spesso, magari,
di cadere, scivolare,
avere i lacci delle punte svolazzanti;
o perdere un oggetto di scena
in un punto del palcoscenico,
dove tu stesso, o magari un ballerino
successivamente, dovrà poi esibirsi.
E oltre a pensare
a quello che si deve fare,
si deve avere la velocità di pensare
a come risolvere questo problema
senza che tutto ciò vada
a compromettere l'intera performance.
E gli imprevisti, come dicevo,
se li si affrontano con prontezza
e non ci rassegnano, appunto,
alla prima difficoltà,
possiamo risolvere tutti i nostri problemi
a colpi di jeté.
Ma avere un sogno non basta.
A volte anche la determinazione
può non bastare, seppure necessaria.
Il segreto, a volte,
sta proprio nel condividere
il vostro sogno con gli altri
e farlo diventare il sogno di tanti.
Il sogno della mia vita si è realizzato
grazie a tutti coloro che mi hanno aiutato
nel momento del bisogno
e che hanno creduto in me
in un momento per me così drammatico.
L'aiuto degli altri,
alcuni anche presenti qui,
mi ha permesso di realizzare il mio sogno.
E io, questo, non me lo dimenticherò mai.
E voi avete già condiviso
i vostri sogni con gli altri?
(Applausi)